that's the story that every christian
korean christian church would tell us
to see like what you're really about
tell about that one girl the little girl
who walked up took her hair down and
started wiping the spit away with her
hair
right right and that was the thing that
everybody would start bawling and crying
well let me tell you about me when i
heard that stuff i was like
i would have spit on me seriously
that's the first thing i thought i felt
like
[ __ ] why why in
five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain
podcast we have our esteemed guest
ed park vp once again and i swear
to [ __ ] baby jesus we are going to
talk about tenants
how many times have we like said we were
going to three sessions we [ __ ] this
up
so this is this is a very so if you guys
are listening to this podcast this
podcast is literally just about
anything and everything but one of the
things that i do like doing is doing
film breakdowns um
and this is about my need broken down to
the to the max
because tenant is one of the most
confusing films i've ever seen in my
life
right and i watched tennant twice
because i was going to hawaii
yeah i went to hawaii twice in the last
month and i watched it two times over
and i still don't [ __ ] get it i still
don't it got to the point where when i
was looking at the film i was thinking
that
this [ __ ] just did this to
confuse us you you
son of a [ __ ] the the hard part is that
it is kind of convoluted
but in a sense of like uh
let's say time what do you call it he's
[ __ ] up time
yeah like it actually makes sense in the
order it comes in yeah
and the the thing is like
whenever christopher nolan makes movies
he makes it to be rewatchable
you're supposed to see it over and over
again which i love
but i think the biggest confusion is
that everyone keeps thinking about time
travel right time travel
yeah i think it's about film editing
okay
so uh you kind of look at
a director's body of work to kind of see
a bigger picture of what they're trying
to
make sometimes with a lot of auteurs
like even
um let's tell people about the premise
of this okay first right
yeah so i mean what is the premise of
this film like it's
tenant is about this is where i have
trouble explaining it right
right because if it's not about time
travel
even the way it started off confused the
[ __ ] out of me right right i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on there's secret
agents that are happening here
this guy is a very particular secret
that's really good at what he does
he somehow he gets knocked out it was
like a test it wasn't
real for something else it was a cyanide
pill
um that he thought was gonna kill him
but it was a test to prove that
he's willing to give it up and not give
up his men
yeah so they bring him into this tenant
organization
right and he starts kind of figuring out
oh he's got to find this plutonium
but as a movie goes on we find out it's
not plutonium it's a device that
reverses entropy
and it gets to that part where he has to
go see that scientist
right and then what does she say don't
think about it
that was the part where at that point
i'm like
[ __ ] christopher nolan you son of a
[ __ ] i think i had a deposit
i paused it and i went wait what did she
just
explain so in this part of the film
they're at a shooting range right
and there are specific slots that have
these items
that went through a certain process that
allows things to be
to go in reverse in time right
specifically it's a weapon it's a gun
right so you see this person the
scientists bring
bring out a gun the the bullet loads up
reverses
and it shoots but when it shoots the
bullet comes back into the right and
this way
right and she goes through this short
diatribe about what this thing is about
and then she goes don't think about it
[ __ ] you what the [ __ ]
man it's basically no one's saying to
the audience
you're not gonna get it suspend your
disbelief yeah yeah right here just
just don't even think about it just like
ride the wave
but as i watch the movie i kind of see
it as an entire collection of his movies
even starting from
memento memento that's his og og one
dude
yeah so what was so special about
memento
uh the movie was [ __ ] backwards too
yeah it was his first instance of trying
to tell about this uh
this disorder this condition that he has
with his amnesia or whatnot
um but told it in a way through film
editing right
uh that told this story backwards but
still made
sense right and it had this crazy
rewatch ability where you can watch it
over and over and from the when you
watch it again
the beginning something makes more sense
because you already kind of know where
it's going
and it's one of those movies where you
can watch it backwards and forwards
and i think he won um an oscar for
uh i think best screenplay original
screenplay
and one of his like movies after that
was the prestige have you seen the
prestige yet
i didn't see it yet so it's about two
magicians
right who are rivals who fight each
other in the turn
of the uh what do you call it the 20th
century
right um so it's like 1899 or some [ __ ]
and that was the movies of the day
because there's no film right
they they set up and like
show an act of magic but they show it
like it's filmmaking like directing
and pre-production and how to make great
tricks
yeah i think it's a whole allegory for
filmmaking and directing
where hugh jackman's character is the
showman right
he's the nolan that made [ __ ] dark
knight
batman begins and all those blockbuster
action movies right
it's all the show and the technology
right and this
big front so that it brings people in
right blockbusters but then there's the
nolan
who's just simple and makes like memento
no cgi just straight from the script
right but who did he write the script
with he wrote it with his brother
jonathan nolan
you know and that's the whole part with
uh
these clone kind of things in the movie
where he's battling with himself between
being this blockbuster
guy and an auteur you know and then you
keep going on to like
inception right which also is a very
[ __ ] confusing movie
and it's a movie about making movies
what
is a dream right what are film
you know if you really think about it
films are dreams
they're dream simulators we really just
made up what we thought in our head and
we put it on the screen that's the
closest thing we get to dream simulation
and what we're saying when we make like
films when we see these things
we're sharing our dreams to our friends
right we're saying we hope you share
this stream too and make
you ma some people might think like your
fans they see a film like that's my
story too
right they got incepted right
so like what's his name uh leonardo
dicaprio
if you look at him in that movie and you
look at christopher roland
he's dressed just like nolan he looks
like christopher nolan oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah slick back hair and all
of his attire
and so he's the director uh ken watanabe
billionaire who buys an entire like
airline so they could have a plane he's
the executive
director who's putting all this [ __ ]
together he wants
this you know his stuff from this guy
and then um you have ellen page where
she's the set designer right tom hardy
is the actor
jgl is the assistant director you know
and it goes on and on
like these people and even maul right
his his dead wife who keeps like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah that's his trauma
of a failed inception where the audience
hated his movie
right a flop like insomnia the way
he's trying to make other movies but he
keeps having this flop in the back of
his head how much
the audience got the wrong idea about
the movie
and what it does to them and how it
affects him yeah
yeah yeah right his movies are
allegories to making movies
right so what's his next movie after
that what did he have to tell
interstellar right now it's not
particularly about making movies but it
is one of the most closest scientific
kind of things about like black holes
and wormholes in
the fifth dimension because by the end
of it what's actually going on when he
goes into that
black hole what is christopher nolan
trying to show us
what's the plot of the movie that fifth
dimensional beings
sent the wormhole to us third
dimensional beings
right so that we can travel through time
the way
they see it because in the fifth
dimension if you look at our time and
he's in that his daughter's bedroom
right yeah and seeing all of these times
in life
it's linear yeah he's outside of it and
he can affect it and manipulate that
space time yeah right and he was trying
to show
like visually show that in interstellar
then what's his next movie dunkirk
what's one of the like the
the temporal pincer move
isn't that one of the things where two
teams going forward and backwards come
together
to hit this one point right so they can
do this heist
he already pulled that idea out in
dunkirk
because he was using his editing in that
film of three different times of three
different events going on but happening
they pincer right they come together
right in the third act
and so when i see this movie right yeah
this is where
where i feel like crazy man because i've
seen this movie like five six times now
yeah yeah yeah
right i think it's his allegory to film
editing
what if so interstellar 5th dimensional
beings third dimensional beings though
a way to edit their timeline
they keep saying someone from the future
sends them
like uh this technology or whatever
right
and what do they figure out how to go
forwards and backwards in time
i think it's like they know they're
two-dimensional beings in a film
because they keep saying what happened
has happened right
and so that means they know they're in
this editing linear time like when you
open up
premiere pro right the entire beginning
to end is there
yeah and you can scroll through it with
the the jog wheel right yeah the
timeline thing
i think the technology is the edit jog
wheel
they gave these characters in the movie
the ability to go forwards and backwards
on the film reel in time but you see
they're not like jumping back
and forth like back to future or they're
rolling
backwards right so
what but what happens happens right
these things
were kind of predetermined which means
like when you shoot something
you can't like change it unless like you
use your editing tricks right unless you
go
and reshoot it and so it's one of these
things when you say what's happened
happen there's no reshoots
yeah i think that's an intent when i was
watching it too
when they go into the machine the
quote-unquote time machine right yeah
and they're going through everything
backwards once they get back to the
present time the future didn't
change much did it it didn't change
right it didn't it didn't change which
is something very odd that you don't see
in time
time films in time films typically what
happens is somebody goes back into the
past
and it's the butterfly effect right
where one small thing
is a ripple effect that changes the
outcome of the future right and this one
it didn't really
have much of that it was they would
intervene like crazy
right and then it would still be the
same i think that would dwell with like
the reason why
endgame and avengers went to the quantum
realm
because quantum mechanics tells us that
there literally could be
multiple universes yeah yeah you know
multiverse
where christopher nolan's not dealing
with that actually right
um and so he kind of stuck to it on the
ground
level where that's why it's just kind of
rolling forward
but also that it doesn't change like
this uh this future it doesn't change
what happened now
what happened now is because something
in the future in backwards happened
and what's happened happened so like
things where his he gets stabbed
and then later it shows he got stabbed
like these things if you keep watching
it over and over if you want to
spend three hours of your life watching
over and over
they do make sense from the especially
the timing of when they start and and
every beginning being an end but
backwards the other way it is convoluted
yeah is confusing but it does make sense
it's just the weird i just the the
fighting backwards thing
confused the [ __ ] out of it right that
[ __ ] was so confusing to me
because there was a part in the film too
where
i mean it's multiple parts right because
things that have happened have happened
and it's and it's a glimpse of what they
saw from them coming back into the past
right so for example when the
uh i forgot her name in the film but she
was the
the mob boss's wife yeah uh cat yeah so
super tall lady exactly
so she's um she has that glimpse of
herself
jumping into the pool or into the ocean
right and for her it was like i want to
be as free as this woman here but that
was actually her
after she had murdered her mob boss
russian husband
yes which was so weird right so it's
like that's her and it's not her at the
same time
and at this point my brain will explode
i'm like i don't get the
[ __ ] is happening right now you know so
that event
and this is why it's so it is convoluted
because
by the third act they say where is he
going where is he gonna go
he's going two weeks from now when he
thought he was the happiest
but we had a big fight and he he would
go back there to end his life
so they go back before the movie
starts yeah an event that she actually
explained earlier in the movie
so they go back to that point to make
what happened happened that
it was actually her who had done that
who jumped off yeah and she thought he
was
cheating on her but actually that was
his future self who went back to the
past to go kill himself
and she cleaned up so the thing is they
already won in the beginning of the
movie
yeah they already won before the movie
started what happens
happens i'm saying what the [ __ ]
is going on man and also too um
when they said he's going back to the
time that he was the happiest right
so that version of himself when he's at
that part where he's having a
conversation with her
he is the future self that's with him
right now
and he doesn't know that she's the
future version yeah
of her which i was so confused at that
point too because i thought
so he would have to be moving backwards
kind of so he's doing
the yeah in the beginning not beginning
in the middle of the movie
um when they go start looking for the
device
right and then they have that whole
chase in the heist down the street and
then
um you already start seeing this
backwards guy yeah right
but when he actually starts going
backwards is much
later you know after they have him
captured
yeah that's when he actually starts
going backwards way after they've
already
finished the heist so when it starts for
like him going back it's like
the beginning for them it is confusing
it is convoluted but from there the bad
guy
is he keeps going backwards but the good
guys for a little bit
just to get their feet on the ground
start going forward again say
uh go back to the armchair like hey
why'd you do that why'd you tell me to
do this and that
then they decide okay looks like he's
keep going back and they go chase him
to the past you know what's so weird too
when whenever i watch
time travel films it always makes me
think about
and i know i don't really have i don't
really have too many regrets right
because i i typically believe
that everything happens for a reason
right right there's there's
bad things there's good things and all
these events that happen in your life
lead to an end result that you can't
replicate if you went back in time and
you try to change
right right whether it's where i am now
with this podcast where it was with
youtube or everything else because i can
go ahead and say well
if i went back in time i would probably
do this content instead and do this this
and that
but you never really know what the
outcome is right because there's so many
variables right but then i always think
too
it's like what because mariel and i and
also her best friend had a conversation
about
if you could go back in time and there
were three things that you would change
what what would they be
and i had to really think about that i'm
like well i don't know because
all the stuff that i might think that i
didn't like now or at that time that i
would have changed
who knows what the end result would have
been who would you be now
exactly would i be now right would i be
here maybe i'd still be living in
sacramento maybe i would have never
pursued
this career in comedy um on a lot of the
stuff like for example too i think a lot
of people want to think about
changing something that will make them
more rich and
give them more money but then at the
same time i also think about
a lot of the struggles that i had also
developed the way that i think now
right and if i didn't if i had that
money and if i had that comfort
it i would be a completely different
person
those struggles are the things that help
mold the way that i think and
how i view life in general you know so
everything when i look about when i look
back and i say i want to change this it
usually has to do with wealth
you know no of course like what would
you do i would go back when bitcoin was
a dollar yeah invest in apple when it
was seven cents
yeah those are the things that i think
about right but who who [ __ ] knows
what would have happened
you know yeah i think more or less this
movie like i said doesn't
um so as it goes on you think that they
got to go in the past to change the
future right well
it already happened it already happened
that's the difference about this time
travel movie
is that what they found out their job
was is to
make what's happened happen yeah not
change the past to change the future not
change anything no
ensure what's happened happens yeah
yeah so that's what's different about it
i believe and
a lot of people might have a hard time
wrapping their head around that
like oh then where's the whole like
where's the satisfaction of saving the
world yeah right
kind of thing um because oh now this
future is so great or whatever
but in actuality if you think about like
back to future 2 he goes back to that
shitty 1985
right the fact of the matter in that
reality is that it still exists
people still suffer and live in that
reality that's what the quantum mechanic
like
multiverse thing is about while
christopher nolan and this one like i
said it's more of a
it's just this what how it affects here
in this reality and this universe is
that
what's happened happened you can't even
change it if you went to the past
because of the paradox
i think that's one of the things yeah
the grandfather paradox yeah
it's one of those things he's trying to
break visually
what is the grandfather paradox it's if
i went to the past
and murdered your harabaji would you be
alive
by it right it's the sarah connor thing
yeah they're trying to kill her to you
know make sure this is john connor yeah
it's it's kind of like that pretty much
which we don't know
because we don't time travel yeah yeah
and
the the motivation for the future people
who want to destroy the past
is that they're hedging their bets that
they'll survive yeah
the multiverse whatever theory that the
past will destroy but we exist
in this universe so they're they're
relying on quantum mechanics that their
future
was sustained because they live in a
place where they destroyed the past
oh that's so confusing yeah
i know i know that's why it's hard for
people to eat but i [ __ ]
i love this movie and it's the
explanation is probably just as
confusing as the [ __ ] film man it is
that is so hard to wrap my [ __ ] head
around man i have to go watch it again
it was meant to it was meant to be
watched again and again and again look
i've seen it five
six times now yeah you know i mean
that's but that's what i love about
movies if you gotta go see it again
and it didn't incept you but you want to
be incepted yeah
yeah it's a good movie if you could if
you could go back in time what are three
things that you would change
let's say let's say this high school
college adulthood high school
um i'll try i'll stop trying so hard
[Laughter]
wouldn't we all bro i was trying to stop
being so hard stop being so funny
stop being so s like unique
yeah stop being so like identified as an
artist and
knowing being what people describe me as
yeah
right yeah that's that's high school
isn't that so weird in high school you
try so hard to be different that you
turn out to not be different
you're just like everybody [ __ ] else
because everybody else is trying to try
so hard to be unique you're
literally a carbon copy of everybody in
your class right which is such a weird
thing to think about where it's like oh
so everyone now wears the same kind of
jeans
yeah and one person did all of us and if
everyone's doing it then
is it cool yeah how cool is it how
unique is it yeah i mean the high school
society
is is confusing but it's one of those
things like i lived through what i did
but honestly if i could but i could in
high school
i would ask to move somewhere else
really and go to some other high school
why why you hated your high school i
[ __ ] hated it i would have rather
been somewhere else for sure
oh this was the high school that you had
to deal with a lot of [ __ ] racist
white people right
yeah yeah and there was even a point
my uncle offered my mom to adopt me
oh really yeah because he had two
daughters he really wanted a son
real bad and then me being the middle
child or whatever is like hey
why didn't you come stay with us hey uh
you don't really care about them
just uh give them to me my mom actually
talked to my dad about it and it was
like
[ __ ] up you got this that's like what
are you asking
yeah it was the dumbest thing i've ever
heard in my life benny had his own son
and that kid is super spoiled so i mean
but like yeah because that event had
happened i
i do think a lot but what if i was just
about that by my uncle
yeah my dad was too right yeah i thought
a lot about that too
you probably would have been more [ __ ]
up to be honest with you because this is
a man who wanted a son
so bad he would have spoiled the [ __ ] oh
yeah and what the [ __ ] happens to every
[ __ ] spoiled kid that we know
the way my cousin turned out
[Laughter]
little [ __ ] [ __ ] bags you know when
everything is given to you man we had
this
very interesting conversation where me
and joe had this conversation right
and we we see this a lot with um
everybody that we're around because i
think that
when you're when you grew up with
nothing right there's this idea
and it's an idea that our parents had
too right or when we had this child
we're gonna make sure that they have
everything that we didn't right that's
that seems to be the parental endgame
like that's the end goal
right but i think there's this other
equation that this is what me and joe
agree about where i think we kind of
convolute
um material wealth giving your child
material wealth versus knowledge
right right right because i don't think
the material wealth is the part that
would have made my life easier as a kid
it's knowledge that would have made it a
lot easier
right right and that's usually like the
key to success for a lot of these people
it's never so much that you pass down
generational wealth
because what happens to a younger
generation and i'm pretty i think i mean
there's i think there's studies about
this [ __ ] too this is not just me
thinking about this out of thin air um
where there's uh people who grew up with
a lot of stuff right
their their cap for excitement is
already at an all-time high because
everything is given to them
that's why they have to go die on the
[ __ ] himalayan mountain
exactly go to mount everest and [ __ ]
die that's why you have these ceos
yeah who [ __ ] get dominatresses to
come in step on their [ __ ] balls
because they need to feel something yeah
right because they are at the top of the
food chain
think about this when you were younger
right think about some of the happiest
moments that you've ever had in your
life
and was it because things were given to
you or because you [ __ ] earned it it
was because you earned
right like those few like here's here's
a great example i remember the first
time i
ever got a brand new pair of air maxes
all right
right and i remember this this air max
that i had that had like these green
bubbles on the inside
and i thought that [ __ ] was the dopest
thing on earth and i also knew that with
this shoe i wasn't gonna get another one
until this [ __ ] was worn out
until that [ __ ] was gonna be flat like
these bubbles had a pop for me to get
new shoes
right but there's this moment of
anticipation that i have to get this new
shoe
and when i get that new shoe again it
feels just as good as i got it the first
time well now take this whole
equation out and say well yeah these are
just givens everything that i own
everything that i have everything that i
quote unquote earn is a given
it's not something that i have to work
for that joy is gone
right i mean the kids who get cars at
16.
yeah what happens to those cars they get
trashed they get trapped there's no
there's no value in something
that you didn't have to work for and i
know that sometimes people think it's
like well why do you want your kids to
struggle well why is earning something
in your life considered a struggle
why why is that ever considered a
struggle why is it not considered
this is a part of life and it's a part
of life that you should enjoy
when you earn things and you make things
for yourself now you can see it
and everybody can see this as celebrity
kids too yeah why the [ __ ] are these
celebrity kids try
why do they try so [ __ ] hard to be
different
why is it that their identity is i'm
something different i'm this
this person who thinks about
existentialism i'm this person who has
to [ __ ]
blow crack out of my [ __ ] into
somebody else's [ __ ] even though they
grew up with millions
exactly like they have to prove how
different they are their their way their
theirs their scent
their sense of excitement is so much
different because everything was given
to them
right you know it's it's super weird and
we've seen this multiple times over
and i had a conversation with a friend
of mine where he was talking to me his
kid he goes i want to make sure
that my kids have everything so whenever
they want a toy daddy's going to get
that toy
daddy's going to make you want to eat
this dedicated make sure you eat this
and i asked them i was like well why do
you want to do that
it's like because i didn't grow up with
much so i want to make sure my kids
have everything so they're successful
and i was like hey you're successful
yeah
so what did your parents [ __ ] up on so
bad that you think that you're not going
to give to your kid
what i wish that i had in terms of what
my parents could give me
was it's not wealth is that if they
were given access to a lot of stuff like
knowledge
it would have been easier for me 100
scholarships right
education how to apply for bank all this
other stuff how do you even apply to
college
you didn't have this knowledge because
parents did it yeah i took
esl classes in kindergarten i'm born in
this country bro
i had to take esl classes because that's
crazy my parents didn't speak english
yeah and so i grew up uh what four years
in in home and then they sent me to
public school
i didn't speak in english that's crazy
grew up in k-town
that's hilarious dude no yeah i could
have been one of those
oh my god hey welcome to cape town
i could have been one of those guys
that's [ __ ] crazy i have no idea
oh yeah i remember those yes like they
pull out flash cards
[Music]
no for sure knowledge had my parents
known better about even the law
yeah the constitution how the government
works or whatever all these things
it's uh we kind of live with the
immigrant mentality still right just
kind of scraping
while we can but i do kind of wish i
just
knew everything legitimately like most
of my white friends do you
get it right their their biggest
leverage is the fact that they had
knowledge so what i'm telling like some
of these people and i'm and i'm seeing
this a lot with
certain parents that i like that i feel
like i'm going to try to mimic
is that they have the same advice too
it's like it's not about giving them
the material things that you felt like
you didn't have when you were a kid it's
about the knowledge
and it's also about the time that you
give your kids right because when we
were younger our parents couldn't give
us that time
they were at the store all day exactly
15 times and we just be home like
waiting for them to go
it's the relationship it's the
conversation that's the stuff that's
important
so like for me when people say like okay
well when you make a gratuitous amount
of money right or you you become rich or
something else
he goes you want to make sure your kids
have all this stuff absolutely [ __ ]
lutely not i'm gonna give them what they
need
if they want nice things i'm pretty sure
but they're gonna have to earn it just
like everybody else
because i would hate to have a child who
thinks that everything in life is
supposed to be given to them and it's
not true
it's just not it's gonna be hard for me
because you know i want to
because i say this now with somebody who
doesn't have a kid right so i know how
difficult it is not to give your child
something
or somebody you love something when you
have the means to do it oh for sure
i mean the whole reason why i told you
when my dad went to prison
yeah i want to buy a bmw
what what yeah i mean he had the wrong
idea for sure i found that up i mean i
was [ __ ] how old was i like 15 when
he told me
yeah actually i was like 17. you know i
was like
that's not what i wanted right but it
was for sure it's just like i wish you
spoke better english
you know i'm not gonna blame you for not
yeah
but i wish you know for everything you
do know i wish you told me to
my dad didn't really pass me off a lot
of like
knowledge let's say yeah yeah um i like
i found out later like
he's a big 49ers fan what the [ __ ] yeah
he likes like uh he was a dodgers fan
like all this [ __ ]
my dad didn't share that [ __ ] with me at
all of course
you know you know apple was a 49ers fan
i'm like huh
yeah he didn't share his life with me
you know and
and in the same case look um i didn't
i didn't get a whole lot of [ __ ] growing
up either yeah so
uh torah and ben got laptops
desktops game boys uh playstation
nintendo nintendo 64 playstation
2 xbox you know these things
i didn't i grew up in a really weird
household
where my brother and sister got this
stuff and i didn't
so when you when you like it was just
christmas time everybody had all these
uh boxes to unwrap and then you just got
an ass whooping
yes dude i have a december birthday
you know so much oh my god my birthday
present is my christmas gift like you
know what you get to open for christmas
like
a whoop ass there's like some
christmases
literally like my siblings have a
present they're like you already had a
present on your birthday
like stuff like that goddamn yeah so i
mean like i have a playstation because i
make money and i bought my own yeah but
tell you what some days i just
i'm not obsessed with it i don't feel
like playing i actually get tired of it
i don't know yeah you know i don't have
too many
i don't have a lot of like toys and
trinkets
and like things that kind of like keep
me going
i buy like a top of the line thing and
just preserve it
and keep it forever i'm more like
in that way because i didn't get much
yeah but it didn't
like having that stuff didn't make me
better or worse
not having that stuff i believe didn't
make me better or worse either
to be honest now it was weird that they
treated me differently
yeah but as far as how i turned out to
be honest it didn't change the way my
life is
just the way i feel like where a little
six-year-old kid inside
is so hurt that he didn't get this and
that
which i'm i get it and i i grow up over
kind of thing i've had to deal with that
stuff
but generally like i definitely get it
like
giving somebody all this [ __ ] too like i
see the spoiledness and the entitlement
that comes out of it and
things that they deserve and things that
they envy
so like just like in tenet the whole
thing about the
his motivation was like if i can't have
you
as my wife then [ __ ] everyone [ __ ] them
right and that turned to be his
motivation if i can't live then [ __ ] the
world
i'm gonna everything needs to go there
are people like that
who are incredibly entitled and envious
over the dumbest things well that's why
i also hate this huge trend where i see
it so [ __ ] much
and it's usually the trashiest [ __ ]
human beings that like to talk like this
they
they like to call each other or their
kids or their daughters their sons and
daughters or whatever
kings and queens it's like this is my
king how was that your [ __ ] king
yeah why are these kids growing up with
the idea that they're [ __ ] royalty
right they don't even know how to
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the toilet yet [ __ ]
these kids right
[ __ ] your kids because and i say this
too because i have a lot of friends who
are educators
and they said that it's really hard when
their parents gassed their kids up so
much to the point
they're they're convoluting being
supportive of your kids and then giving
them a [ __ ] big head
and showing their potential yeah
and and like what they could be and
convoluting it with a [ __ ] fairy tale
you're king you're gonna be a king one
day hey
there's no such thing as kings you're in
the united states of florida
dude there's no [ __ ] royalty here
you're not a king i'll tell you what
my parents did that to us they told us
that
my grandma grew up in the palace in
korea
which is semi true my my great
grandfather was some sort of politician
or something [ __ ]
but then when we said oh so that are we
princess and my parents like yeah
and i ran around thinking i'm a korean
prince [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i tell you what that lie didn't
help me or do me any good
yeah i wish my parents told me that i
kind of like
shudder like why did i go around telling
people it's green prince you know
remember in my sassy girl when they when
they had that moment he goes never tell
your kids that they're smart
right right and that's that's the
problem too right it's like you have
it's like you're smart like your dad
you're so so you're you got your smarts
from me so you should be
smarter than i am yeah you know because
you start becoming a lazy [ __ ]
right because you think that knowledge
is given to you now you're so [ __ ]
smart you don't have to study you don't
have to do anything else
things are just supposed to be the way
that it is and they're they're thinking
and i truly believe this that you really
think that when you keep calling your
kids kings and queens or whatever
that you're boosting up their
self-esteem but what you're doing is
you're actually making them
[ __ ] um they're not living in the
same world that everybody else is
you can do it by telling them that
they're important and their feelings
matter
and that they're good people but to say
that they're this
this royalty is is ridiculous and i know
people are going to say
those are just words david they do
something positive for the kid but i'm
telling you it's not
and this is coming from the mouth of
people who are young educators who are
elementary school teachers that have to
deal with these [ __ ] kids
and it's that idea where they walk and
they're like i'm a queen you can't tell
me what to do
it's like who the [ __ ] told you this
[ __ ] mommy and daddy told me this
can i tell you some [ __ ] up story yeah
so i was at this this is way
back it was like 10 years ago i was at
this get-together with church people
right and there's a new church i'm
trying out
and i don't know where the conversation
went but i was like
dude i met somebody named precious the
other day i was like dude that's
ridiculous why would you name your kid
precious that sets them up for failure
yeah right and i was like
like seriously who would name their kid
perfect
that's dumb and then someone's like oh
uh pastor's daughter's name is perfect
she was [ __ ] out of here
never coming back so if you had that
time machine
i mean if it was tenant rules i'd be
going backwards to myself
you wouldn't understand what i'm saying
you have to figure out a way to say shut
the [ __ ] up
so if you had a time machine yeah that's
the moment it's one of those moments for
sure
named their kid [ __ ] perfect perfect
that [ __ ] got bullied
possibly that [ __ ] got bullied her
whole life i'm going after that
because i felt like an idiot i would
have just laughed my ass off
i literally would have laughed my
[ __ ] ass off
that's the real man dude i've had some
weird ass church moments man there's
actually
i'll tell this story i i didn't want to
tell the story because i was going to
put it into a film but i'll tell you
either way it doesn't [ __ ] matter
it'll be in the film anyway so when i
was
when i went to uc uh my
the uc that i went to right a little too
specific at time i went to multiple
colleges
so i don't embarrass this person but
there was somebody that i knew from
sacramento
that went over to the uh
the college that i went to right he came
a little bit later yeah so he was trying
to get me to join their praise team
and so i did um me being a good
christian boy i was like okay let me get
let me go to this
this church here at the time i didn't
want to go to a korean church because i
didn't like korean churches
but i was willing to give this a try
because of him so they wanted me to join
the praise team
um i didn't really get along with the
the main praise leader he was kind of
like a douchebag right and in my mind
i'm just like bro if it wasn't for the
love of god i would
smash it because he was like one of
those dudes he was you could tell he's a
major church oppa
he loves kind of showing how strong and
powerful he is how much leadership he
has how much god loves how many
chairs he can hold exactly how many
folding chairs watch me [ __ ] do this
table by myself
you little stupid [ __ ] but
there was this moment where the he would
lead
a small group and the pastor was there
as well
and he wanted to meet some of the new
praise team members and so he's leading
the small group the pastor is there as
well
and we got to this moment where we're
strong we're supposed to have this
moment where we
we talk to each other and we what is
that part where you can kind of tell
stuff about yourself what do you call
money testimony so everybody is giving
their testimony right
and i'm giving a very small version of
myself because i don't know these people
i don't want
to know everything about me and so this
guy is about to come on he's about to
give his testimony
here's the thing i know him i know him
very well
and there's a whole other backstory to
it that i won't go into but long story
short with this guy he tells
a story about how he tried to kill
himself
right i know the backstory to this to
this right
so in my mind i'm thinking why is he
going to tell the story
but he starts going into this and he
goes
so like oh he has a korean accent by the
way
so this dude uh born in the states he
moved back to korea moved back to the
states moved back to korea move back to
the states
so he has a thick korean accent can't
speak korean or english well
the worst situation ever so he's like so
i want to tell you guys like i tried to
kill myself
and so he's telling the story
and he goes so i
jumped i i jumped out of a window and
i tried to kill myself and i broke my
leg and i survived
right and the pastor looks at him and he
says
well why'd you try to kill yourself he
was like because i felt like
i couldn't do anything right and i went
i went
i know the pastor looks at me he goes
are you laughing
why are you laughing i was like you
gotta admit it's kind of funny that the
reason why he's trying to kill himself
because he can't do anything right he
can't kill himself
the room goes silent yeah the pastor
looks at me i [ __ ] you not
starts dying oh no he starts cracking
the [ __ ] up he starts
and then the room starts dying laughing
and
i'm you know with me when i'm laughing
i'm laughing my
ass off dude yeah i was like how [ __ ]
ironic is this [ __ ]
that full hasn't talked to me in almost
10 years it's been a long time he was
he stopped being a part of the praise
team and he never came back out
i mean [ __ ] look i told my story on jk
similar story
everyone laughed because i meant it to
be funny
yeah it is funny yeah i think the
problem is that couldn't
he couldn't see it that way he took it
too personally well because he was
trying to do this whole
you know when some people in church when
they do their testimony you could tell
they're trying to get a dramatic
reaction from everybody
he starts off and i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
and i leave these details out a lot
because it's not important to the story
but
you'll hear a lot of people if you go to
church you know what i'm talking about
where somebody's about to give their
testimony they go
how do i know how do i know this you
know this guys
you guys the [ __ ] ear on the shoulder
it's like yeah yeah cut cut the dramatic
acting out just tell your [ __ ]
testimony [ __ ]
because now you're trying to you're
trying to create a tear jerker aren't
you talking about like the same reason
like because
a lot of us has given have been given a
lot yeah right
and perhaps being around so many
suburbanites
where we see other privileged kids and
everyone is just as basic as each other
that you you said they gotta be unique
yeah they gotta have something else
and maybe they thought [ __ ] up stories
is the way that they can relate to
he doesn't really have much problems
either his father's a very he owns like
a very prominent law firm
in korea yeah so this kid is a little
rich kid
and so he's trying to one-up people's
testimonies it's like bro you ain't
gotta do all that
just tell who you are this is a moment
for us to get to know each other
like i could have gone into that story
and said hey like i grew up in a pretty
[ __ ] up family my parents used to beat
the [ __ ] out of me
you know all this other stuff but that's
not really what it's for it's just me
telling a little bit about who i am
where i'm from where i want to go
and that it's very nice to meet people
but this will fall over here you would
have thought there was a spotlight on
him
you know and he's holding up an empty
skull like it's shakespeare like [ __ ]
tell your [ __ ] story
i've been in that situation where uh i
felt
pressured to talk about things that i
want to talk about because
i went to this bible study meeting for a
church here in la
okay and then there was like a good
amount of people somewhere around
less than 10 though but
the leader of the bible study started
like telling about her abusive past
you know and getting really open about
it and
crying about like what happened to her
and it was it was bad you know but being
very open and honest about it
and just saying exactly what she's
living through and how she's dealing
with it
right wow right and then she goes all
right
now why don't you guys pour you know
pair up and talk about your traumas with
each other
what the [ __ ] i don't know anybody here
i'm not gonna tell them like what the
[ __ ] i'm going through
you just said you sit down you look it
up so my dad sold meth
yeah seriously what do you want me to
say
yeah i was like oh man where are you
yeah
you know why how is this gonna serve you
help you or even
let you know where i'm coming like yeah
i was just like
i went into my little group it was like
three
of us dudes because the rest of them
weren't like women i was like hey guys
i'm not gonna tell you anything all
right and they're like me too i'm not
gonna say anything
right yeah okay this is weird and then
we hear like other people in the group
like
like crying and was like no we're not
gonna do that
it's very weird too because there are
certain people who kind of
they kind of take advantage of the whole
religious system to
either make them feel better about what
they're going through rather than trying
to help other people out
right and there have been parts of like
christianity that i've
you know that i've never really
participated in that seems more
cultish than more christian right it
happens
when they break you down
into nothing so you know you're a sinner
you think you're worthless and you're
going to hell
yeah the other side of that being is the
cultish part just happens when
they put you down then lift you up under
their rules
yeah yeah yeah yeah i got lost in that a
lot see and
that's the thing too and i think when it
came to this my father was a pastor
so i grew up with the religion my whole
life right
it's it's not something that's very
foreign to me but
it almost seemed when i went to some of
these other church events
they were trying to get me to a breaking
point right
because they would do this where they
would put the hand on the shoulder
let me pray for you what are you going
through and i'm like
life's really good
you know i'm crazy i'm fantastic
but they wouldn't get that and so
there's like oh you're not willing to
accept god right like
it's not that i'm not willing to accept
you break that heart you know break that
ice cold heart break those callous
layers all the christianities right
yeah christian he's exactly what it is
your heart is callous right now
and you need god to enter your life
right now and break you free from these
chains
right right but i'm fine yeah and they
didn't want to hear that
and so that's where it became really
problematic at me where i looked like i
was the problem person
and it's not that i looked at them like
they were stupid it's just oh you got to
move on to somebody else yeah i'm here
for god i'm here you know i'm i'm kind
of good
yeah you know my relationship with my
parents might not be that great but
that's not information that you're privy
to yet
i don't know you like that you know but
when we have these huge groups
they have that thing where they're
people are bawling and they're crying
and they break them down and they go
well in order for you to be happy
these are the steps that you have to
follow now which that's the part that
bothered me that's not how christianity
works
yeah it's that the idea is that you've
been set free
even though you've despite the way you
feel you know and instead they start
twisting it towards rather than um let's
just
be christian here and talk about the
freedom of jesus on the cross
and what that does for you yeah and what
that means in the gospel
instead it means now you got to abide by
our rules now you have to be
institutionalized
you don't bow down to the throne bow
down to our institution
and not do it this way uh post on your
social media this way
and drink this way eat this way live
this way and then they parent you
yeah that's when you know it's [ __ ] up
is that liberation
is that really freedom it's truly free
indeed
no it was just a weird experience for me
and i think i grew up in such a in a
different in a different like a
christian environment that when i went
to college and there was these
you know these christian groups in the
school that were like that
right it bothered me it irritated me it
made me want to go back to my church i
was like this is not what i'm used to
i'm used to people allowing they say hey
if you want to come
feel free if you don't feel comfortable
that's okay there's always next week
you know there was no pressure there was
there was no
hey what's wrong with your heart they
never pointed fingers
and so when i went into some of these
small groups and i'm pretty sure other
people have experiences as well
it made me feel like there was something
wrong here you know this isn't it
i grew up in that hard pressure
christianity
about like your [ __ ] righteousness
your good deeds the looks the korean
style
yeah of christianity of how good you
look
and uh yeah there's a lot of that's the
whole reason with going to
you know iraq yeah is that yeah shout
out to that
by the way yeah it was just like being
like what the [ __ ] is this really about
man
um like all of these church rules when
you kind of travel
you start realizing they only apply to
korean american truth
that's a small [ __ ] sect of people
we're like why do we behave this way
you know what was funny um somebody
somebody said there's one thing that was
very profound to me
yeah and it kind of made me think they
go we i was
i used to i used to be that dude in high
school that would have that
really popular christian book do you
know which one i'm talking about i think
he had a burgundy cover on it
ah again it was super pop it was like
like jazz or something
it was the most popular christian book
out there it
was it uh purpose driven life purpose
dropped okay
purpose [ __ ] driven life hallelujah
so i used to get i used to have copies
of that [ __ ] i used to give that out to
people
you know what i had i had a book like
that too that changed my life it was
uh it's called crazy love by francis
chan i used to buy copies and give it
out to people yeah i was like hey you
should read this and i gave it to a
couple of people and then somebody
[ __ ]
said something to me that irritated me
but later on i was like
damn that's actually something i should
think about oh so what's like the whole
christian and they weren't trying to
attack me or anything
right i took offense to it because i'm a
young person when i get challenged the
first thing i want to do is be defensive
so they said oh yeah like so do you
think people
christians are religious people who are
really about what they do like they're
they're like the most hardcore and let
me go i was like yeah i think so
like when people love christ like they
follow through with it they go cool i
was like well have he
he said well have you heard of like
buddhist monks who would light
themselves on fire
for believing in what they believe and
i'm like he goes would you do it
i'm like [ __ ]
you know i'm like oh [ __ ] you know like
oh
i i don't know and i'm like no that's
completely different he goes no that's
not different like that's real [ __ ]
right would you like yourself on fire
and then he started bringing up like the
muslim religion
he goes you know muslims they wake up
before
dawn and they pray until the [ __ ] sun
comes up or the sun goes down
right and heard that [ __ ] every morning
yeah in
iraq they get on a microphone it's good
yeah that's when you know you had to get
up and pray like that's [ __ ] they they
do it
daily yeah yeah this guy he was like a
hardcore
he was he was um agnostic right
and so he's like there are other
religions out there that i don't see
them devoting themselves as much as
christians do i say i see them being
very prosperous
but if you look at the muslim religion
he goes thinking about even buddhism
were they where they bow like a thousand
[ __ ] times in the morning and you
started giving me the examples and i'm
like
trying to get socked bro in the name of
jesus
but he did have a point here you know
that i that i you know i was all about
this christ life
but it turns out that guy actually knew
more about the religion that i was
trying to tell people than i knew about
myself
yeah which was crazy to me oh yeah and
that's when i was like hey boy you
better start reading this bible
because this [ __ ] who's agnostic
um
he believes like in a higher being yeah
but doesn't believe in religion
in and of itself knows more about your
religion than you do and you're the one
who you're trying to give people this
purpose-driven life book right
you know right and that's the kind of
thing i was
having a crisis with was my integrity
because of the very thing you said was
just like
these buddhists are hardcore these these
muslims are hardcore
um like what am i doing with my life you
know
yeah and the mis i'd say one this was
kind of a mistake
that kind of radicalized me i started
reading books on christian martyrs
like thick like this is like thick ass
book of all these stories that's a book
i would avoid
yeah like being like if it came down to
it
you know if there was a gun in my head
would i profess jesus you know
like and i was wanted to live that life
and be about that
so that's why i started digging deep and
trying to be about it
then i realized like it's not the works
it's not about the [ __ ] i've done that
says oh he's a real christian because
the bible tell you that's not what
christianity
is is either right i've had to believe
in god in the first place to have to
believe that he's going to keep me safe
out there
you know i've done other things look did
i tell you about the time i
walked three four days straight 60 miles
no food no water no extra clothes
the backpack and i walk 60 miles in the
she goes to korea
just preaching the gospel begging for
food and water
why because i had to prove i'm i'm
christian
this is what jesus commanded in
how did you luke that dude i survived
because i believed in god i
really think jesus is real he's going to
take care of me and he did
i say that that's great i don't got that
i did that [ __ ] three times
three different years i did it again and
again
a year after because your feet must have
been [ __ ] oh yeah
aching they hurt like a [ __ ]
dude i trust in the jesus
how many miles were you walking per day
i'm gonna say about
could be about man 15
to 20 that's crazy dude because when i
was doing my walks earlier like two
years ago
like every day i was doing like 10 miles
yeah and then my
feet would have a heartbeat yeah because
they were pulsing
they told us each time it's 100
kilometers
100 kilometers that's 60 miles right and
you just walk around
like hello yeah and many higher veggies
whatever in in a town i walk by anybody
i come across
just be like i just say do you have any
water because i don't have water
you have any food or whatever just like
what are you doing
you know i'm with the korean group too
anyways and then we just start to talk
to people and just tell them what we're
up to
did you ever convert anybody like that
or they were just like yeah
like what are you doing i think it was
in their head you know
koreans it was very shinseki but then
they fed us
they treated us so well they made sure
we were going to be okay
even at a restaurant we came by we're
just like hey uh we don't have any food
we're just kind of
pilgrimy and this restaurant just gave a
bad bowl of fried rice because it was
whatever he had wow
and then other people here have some
tsubak here have some
kind of people do oh yeah i i'd go to we
go to a church knock on the door be like
uh
we've just been walking can we sleep
here tonight all right
come on in eat and then they feed us and
then we'd sleep there and then we'd be
on our way in the morning
wow one time we were walking and we
you know in korea all these churches
have read like
the online crosses right yeah and we
didn't see one for [ __ ] hours we were
freaking the [ __ ] out we were like where
the [ __ ] are we where there's no red
crosses in korea yeah
it's just real yeah holy [ __ ] and we
kept going and going and it was like 12
or midnight we finally found the church
this pastor was so angry at us and he
was not welcoming
he was like what the hell are you guys
doing here why don't you call me ahead
and say you were coming and we're like
we're just coming by town and it's like
just not like
you're not welcome but you should sleep
here whatever pastor said that and
we're sitting there it's like 1 almost 2
a.m we're tired as [ __ ]
we go back to the bible and read exactly
what jesus says when you go out and do
this task
if you're not welcome does this thus
this
dust off your feet and go to the next
town wow
we [ __ ] did it we just left and we
kept walking till like four in the
morning
until we finally found another church
with a big
white cross instead it's like four in
the morning we knock
and this guy he opens up what are you
guys doing he's kind of freaked out
we're like oh we're just walking or
whatever and he was just up for sabikido
wow he woke up to pray and we are just
looking to sleep so these kind of things
just kind of happen and we
lived survived we weren't in any serious
trouble
but it tested my faith to be desperate
for god
you know that's the kind of christianity
like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is real kind of christian that's
crazy yeah
that's [ __ ] nuts dude and there's
like this i just shared [ __ ] this
you know he's just like coming come in
yeah and most of the place it was just
one church where this pastor was a
[ __ ] dick but
generally everyone else was just like
all right i mean
that's [ __ ] testing my faith tested
really
like how much i what it means to rely on
god
when you pray what are you really
praying about instead of just stupid
[ __ ] prayers
yeah yeah yeah yeah like you know how
you pray before you meal
dear god thank you for the students his
name is amen right how did you know my
exact prayer
yeah that's my exact place instead but
if you've been like
[ __ ] desperate you're like um this
really
incredible gratitude appreciation but
isn't that so interesting too
it's just i mean that's a very extreme
form of what we were talking about yes
yeah when it comes to it is extreme
it's it's it's that form of not having
that allows you to be grateful for what
you do receive
that is the part that i think a lot of
people are missing
just this concept of a phone right
instant knowledge this is a world of
instant gratification and when we don't
get
instantly gratified from things we think
that something is wrong with the
apparatus not us
right right it's there's something wrong
with you that you feel that you are
entitled to be instantly gratified with
everything that you do
like we're kind of complaining about
facebook algorithms now
but at the same time you don't have to
be on facebook exactly
no it's 100 true you know and
it's weird when i think about that too
where
like your story is very [ __ ] extreme
you guys are [ __ ] full-blown idiots
but at the same time at the same time
those are the experience that you take
with you where you get to
live this eye of graciousness yes you
get to be very grateful for the things
that you have yeah this is why i would
take these kids on mexico mission trips
and that's the easiest one
right and even then they couldn't even
handle that [ __ ] right you know it was
hard for them
did you ever hear this story uh i feel
like every christian kid might have
heard the story but it's a story about
the
i think it was either the russian or
chinese right but it's somewhere where
christianity is banned
and these soldiers uh
came in into this church right this is a
church that was a rinky-dink church that
they're not supposed to set up because
it's against the law and if you're
caught
worshiping jesus christ you're supposed
to [ __ ] die yeah and so these
soldiers come in
and he tells they they [ __ ] have guns
they tell everybody to get on the floor
get on their knees
they throw a bible to the floor and they
tell everybody to spit on the bible
right
i've read that story in that really big
book yes
i know that's the story that every
christian korean christian church would
tell us
to see like what you're really about and
tell about that one girl the little girl
who walked up took her hair down and
started wiping the spit away with her
hair
right right and that was the thing that
everybody would start bawling and crying
well let me tell you about me when i
heard that stuff i was like
i would have spit on that seriously
i felt like [ __ ] why
the girl was wiping their hair with this
but i didn't cry i was like she's gonna
brush yeah
yeah yeah they're gonna kill her yeah
i'm not about that life i i read those
stories when i was 16 17.
yeah like i need to be about that life
yeah right but then i came down to it
and traveled the world and been in some
situations
right where you really had to think
about what
god does care and doesn't care about
really
um and it's in this movie called silence
uh have you seen it
no so last time i was here talking about
japanese uh persecution of christians
right yeah um how they brought out
brought back crucifixion and [ __ ] right
um
so this movie is made by martin scorsese
about that
in in the 18 early 1800s in japan
with the spanish and dutch like
missionaries going to japan
and it it starts to really expose you to
like
i mean obviously i related to it so much
being a missionary early in my life
but it's about what the [ __ ] is
important you know
like your jesus cross statue like your
necklace
right people revere this piece of
jewelry
way more than they actually do jesus
like yeah they revere a piece of paper
like the bible
more than jesus himself right like uh
i was shooting this b-boy event in
seattle and it's at a church called the
vineyard everybody goes there all the
time
and um i didn't have a stand for my
camera and i need to get some low shot
of these b-boys
so i found some spare bibles right and i
laid it on the floor to
mount my camera on and this little b-boy
kid he was like
oh you shouldn't be doing that you know
it's like
people find reverence for things that
aren't exactly
actually holy yeah you have to say
that's a piece of paper
that's a piece of metal that's just some
[ __ ] water
you know yeah that's just a piece of
bread and that's just wine
you know i think people get convoluted
to on the
holiness of an object the holiness of an
act
instead of what does it really mean like
if you spit on a picture of jesus
is jesus gonna be like this [ __ ]
i'm never gonna let you win
is he yeah is that the gospel yeah or
did god so loved the world
despite everything we've already done
yeah is the gospel the fact that no
matter how much a piece of [ __ ] we are
is that he still died on the cross and
he's still
one the idea even that like the amazing
thing about the bible
2000 years ago was that they had this
concept
of an eternity right timelessness
out of our linear perception of time
because i just pictured myself in that
moment
this this russian or chinese soldier
comes and they break in
and like this is how even as a 14 15
year old the only thing i thought about
was me going
[Laughter]
but think about it let's say you did
that right yeah and you're cool with
yourself like i did it i'm alive
who's going to judge you jesus or the
other people at the church
that guy spit on jesus no you spat on a
picture
of a white jesus yeah yeah yeah yeah he
adopted
i was like listen i'll go to live and
tell the story another day
and then i'll spread the gospel yeah how
about that yeah
you'd be like one time i tricked these
troops these chinese years
they thought that i was sinning it's not
a but they didn't know i drank some holy
water earlier
so i just baptized that bible oh yeah it
was all clear but that's the weird thing
like i i just remember these moments
where they're trying to make you feel
bad all the time they'll always try to
make me feel bad
i'm like where where's the loving part
of this you know and then you know i
i say this as these are very funny
stories to me you know now
yeah and i don't see this happening a
lot nowadays this is something that
probably happened
in our generation because now i feel
like the church is a lot more
they're they're a little more like okay
this is traumatizing we should cut this
[ __ ] out
but this is how it was for us growing up
yeah just hearing these terrible stories
yeah i'm not gonna lie like i
participated in that method too for sure
because in my head was like oh that's
how i got saved
yeah i got torn down i had to know i was
a sinner
then jesus the gospel of jesus had to
lift me up like that's kind of the
method
i that's the calvinist method too
but um i i just don't see how like
christianity in itself can tell you like
you're actually a piece of [ __ ] but it's
okay you're gonna go to heaven as a
piece of [ __ ]
yeah that's the gospel is that even
though you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
going to heaven
then we start realizing when we live
with the idea of
being shitty all the time it's not
actually healthy
yeah yeah doesn't help us when we have
to rely on this higher power to
give us this authority to become better
people instead of just being a good
person because you have the capability
too
exactly just because you can exactly
yeah yeah
well that wraps up this episode we
talked about today
we finally talked about tenant i swear
to [ __ ] everything
we were going to talk about that film
let me tell you that explanation did
nothing for me yeah
but if you guys haven't watched this
film watch it and then try understanding
what was going on it's a very
christopher nolan is interesting layered
very layered yeah give that a watch you
can find ed at ed parkvp
and then was it your podcast uh bible
study at momo bible study
at momo and we'll see you all next time
peace